for you at the top
happy tax day to those who celebrate
which we hope is everyone in the room
bring back the money
as part of tax day we're highlighting
the real difference between the
president and congressional republicans
president biden has a simple philosophy
the middle class deserves some financial
breathing room which is why his economic
plan would give tax relief to tens of
millions of families families who work
hard and deserve a little extra cushion
each month and the president believes
billionaires should pay their fair share
so we can invest in our economic future
and cut the deficit that's why he's
calling on the top one percent of the
top one percent to pay a minimum tax of
20 percent when right now the wealthiest
families can pay a lower average rate
than teachers and let me be crystal
clear the president will not raise taxes
for anyone making under four hundred
thousand dollars the congressional
republican plan however as senator rick
scott outlined couldn't be more
different republicans on capitol hill
are more than happy to pass a nearly two
trillion dollar tax giveaway to the
wealthy and big corporations under the
previous they were under the previous
administration but now led by senator
scott republicans want to raise taxes on
the middle class
with one independent analysis showing
their plan would hike taxes by an
average of around fifteen hundred
dollars each year on seventy five
million american families ninety six
percent of whom make under one hundred
thousand dollars that's the plan of
congressional republicans tax hikes for
the middle class tax hikes for the
wealthy and big corporations president
biden disagrees it's time to put the
middle class first tomorrow as you may
know the president is traveling to new
hampshire
to highlight infrastructure investments
to modernize our nation's ports and
waterways and discuss how these
investments will strengthen our supply
chain support local economies and help
cut costs for american families american
ports are a cornerstone
of the united states economy but
outdated infrastructure and the covet 19
pandemic have strained their capacity in
jeopardized global supply chains which
has caused delays and passed costs
directly to consumers thanks to the
bipartisan infrastructure law we now
have 17 billion dollars to upgrade
repair and maintain our nation's port
infrastructure as the president
continues to use every tool to help
bring down prices for americans
investments that strengthen domestic
supply chains and move goods faster and
more efficiently are critical to
lowering costs for families so during
his trip tomorrow he will visit
portsmouth harbor which is the only deep
water harbor in new hampshire and
handles approximately three point
million tons and nearly two billion
dollars of cargo a year including
critical materials to support the local
economy and clean energy production the
port recently completed a project to
widen the harbors turning basin and will
receive funding from the bipartisan
infrastructure law to maintain safe and
efficient operations along the channel
both crucial projects to accommodate
larger ships and heavier loads of cargo
also wanted to note a bunch of
scheduling things today um today we are
pleased to announce that we will co-host
the second global 19 summit virtually on
may 12th alongside belize germany
indonesia and senegal the virtual summit
will redouble our efforts to end the
acute phase of the pandemic and prepare
for future pandemics and other health
threats our role in co-hosting the
summit continues to highlight is to
continue to highlight american
leadership in the global covid response
with our provision to date of more than
19 billion dollars in health
humanitarian and economic assistance and
our commitment to providing 1.2 billion
vaccine doses to the world for free of
which we've already delivered more than
500 million doses and while we are
dedicated to continuing to lead the
global coveted response we also need
congress to urgently do its part to fund
the global covet response we have
requested a supplemental funding package
for our most urgent needs to get shots
into the arms and to provide life-saving
tests treatments and supplies and we
will obviously continue to work with
congress on getting that funding when
they return finally i wanted to last
thing is that
we also announced that on march 12th and
13th the president will host the leaders
of the asean
in washington d.c it will build on
president biden's participation in the
october 2021 u.s asean summit where the
president announced 102 million dollars
in new initiatives to expand our
engagement with asean and covet 19
promoting economic growth and more
and this will of course uh we'll have
more to to preview as we get closer to
that trip josh wants to kick us off
thanks jen uh happy monday two minutes
subject areas
first a federal judge in florida says
the cdc exceeded its authority with the
mass mandate in airports that's the
white house position the cdc recommended
continuing the order for additional time
two weeks to be able to assess the
latest science in keeping with its
responsibility to protect the american
people so this is obviously a
disappointing decision the cdc continues
recommending wearing a mask in public
transit as you know this just came out
this afternoon so right now the
department of homeland security who
would be implementing and the cdc are
reviewing the decision and of course the
department of justice
would make any determinations about
litigation
secondly russia is expected to virtually
attend meetings of the imf and world
bank this week
is that appropriate given the actions in
ukraine and how should international
organizations treat russia
well the president has made clear that
he does not believe we should be
operating as business as usual and he's
made clear about his concerns about
their participation in the g20 i'd also
note that our representative there the
secretary of treasury has made clear
that she isn't planning to attend
events or meetings that the russians are
participating in but in terms of other
determinations beyond that i don't have
any further comment
a question on this move to restart the
sale of leases for drilling on public
lands
how long do you think it will take for
these new leases to actually start
producing and what impact do you think
this may have on gas prices
well let me first say that today's
action as you know but for everybody uh
was the result of a court injunction
that we continue to appeal and it's not
in line with the president's policy
which is to ban additional leasing
because
one we need to move towards a more clean
energy economy which he strongly
believes in but also because there are 9
000 permits
unused on lands that could be tapped
into by oil companies and we don't feel
they are needed in terms of how long it
will take to get up
drilling because of the court action i
don't have any assessment on that from
here i would just note that we are going
to continue to
fight this court injunction that is
forcing our hand and allowing this to
proceed even as we have taken actions to
reduce by 80 percent the areas to lease
and impose stringent environmental
standards the president has promised to
slash greenhouse gas emissions in half
by 2030.
now you're having to expand production
of fossil fuels when you promise to
curtail them congress as we know has yet
to act on many of your climate proposals
is the president's ambitious climate
change goal and agenda still attainable
or are these new leases going to
undercut that pledge well again these
leases are not in line with our policy
or the president's view um
you know policy or not i mean this is
the situation that you're in it is and
we're going to continue there's there's
obviously we're going to continue to
fight uh this legal action um but i
would say that um you know the president
remains committed addressing the climate
crisis is one of the four pillars that
he came in he ran on as president and he
will continue to fight for uh one of the
reasons that this was so troubling to
him is because he is so committed to
that
that objective as president and we
continue to propose have continued to
propose a historic investment in
addressing the climate crisis uh
something that we will continue to
discuss with congress so there are a lot
of ways to get there
that we will continue to work with
congress to take actions but he is also
not hesitated to take actions himself
through his own uh
authorities to take actions to help our
climate so but are you still confident
that goal is achievable we are
continuing to pursue it and we are going
to continue to do everything we can to
reach it
oh thank you house minority leader kevin
mccarthy is saying uh president putin
probably would have backed off from
invading ukraine if president biden had
shipped weapons to ukraine sooner
does the president feel he should have
acted well first i mean just for facts
sake um we sent a record amount of
security assistance to ukraine during
president biden's first year in office
more than any other president
in history
and we shared a significant amount of
intelligence with ukraine about russia's
intentions and military movements as you
all know because we've talked about in
here 3.2 billion total 2.6 billion since
this conflict started that's in direct
contrast with
our predecessor who withheld hundreds of
millions of dollars in military aid from
ukraine including javelins which mr
mccarthy who was critical of us in this
moment defended at the time as quote the
rightful thing to do because he claimed
people believed there was corruption in
the zelinski administration so i don't
know if that's a question for us as much
as a question for him what has changed
in that period of time and secondly are
you planning more sanctions this week on
russia more oligarchs what can you tell
us
we are continuing to review and consider
additional sanctions
it's been an ongoing process but
right now you will so you will see us
continue to expand our sanctions targets
and to continue to take steps to both
further tighten our sanctions to to
prevent evasion and
and put in place additional sanctions i
also wanted to note a couple of comments
for anyone who questions which probably
isn't anyone in this room but maybe uh
whether these sanctions are having an
impact
one is by the chairwoman of the russian
national central bank who said these
sanctions are quote will now begin to
increasingly affect the real sectors of
the economy and quote practically every
product she also said that quote that
sanctions are being tightened almost
every day and quote the period during
which the economy can live on reserves
is finite meaning these are really
having the squeeze that the president
the secretary of state the secretary of
treasury treasury and others have
conveyed but we are continuing to review
and i expect we'll have more in the
coming uh days
just to quickly follow up on the mask
mandate being voted by this judge what
is the white house's assessment of what
that means for travelers today
well it just happened this afternoon and
so the department of homeland security
is over obviously overseas of the
implementation of this and they're
reviewing it as we speak so it's still
in place right now
they're doing it as we speak it just
came out this afternoon and if there are
any updates while i'm out here i'm sure
we can provide them to all of you okay
and president zielinski told jake tapper
yesterday that he wants president biden
to visit ukraine and he believes that he
will you said last week there were no
plans being made for president invited
to go is that still the case that has
not changed what our focus continues to
be on is providing ukraine the ukrainian
government ukrainian leaders a historic
amount of security assistance assistance
that's been adapted based on their needs
and their successes on the grounds and
obviously that can be attributed largely
to the courage and the bravery of
ukrainian leaders but but the second
reason is because of the military
assistance we provided
i would note because i know this is an
understandable question you all have
asked that
if anyone were to go there's no plans
for the president to go so let me just
reiterate that but we would not uh
outline from here or anywhere from the
government who if and when for security
reasons so we wouldn't have any details
to preview regardless is the president
considering granting president
zolinski's request to make russia a
state sponsor of terrorism
so that is a process that it's an
authority that obviously exists within
the government and at the state
department and
in order just broadly speaking for for
any country to be designated a state
sponsor of terror and there's only three
north korea sudan and iran at this point
in time just for your full perspective
the secretary of state would need to
determine the government government of
that country has repeatedly provided
support for acts of international
terrorism and these of course
designations are made after a careful
review so while we have those
authorities
i don't have any update on that or
prediction of that that assessment would
be made by the state department what i
would know which i think is important is
that for the countries that have been
designated state sponsors of terrorism
so i named a couple of them for you
that the four main categories of
sanctions that result from designation
under these authorities include
restrictions on u.s foreign assistance a
ban on defense exports and sales certain
controls over exports of dual use items
and other financial restrictions and
what we've already done to date is of
course
impose significant financial
sanctions export controls and curtailed
restrictions on financial assistance so
when you're thinking about uh the impact
these are already a lot of steps that
we've taken but i have nothing to
predict on that front that's a that's a
process that would have to be reviewed
through the state department okay last
question russia warned the united states
last week to stop arming ukraine or risk
unpredictable consequences what does the
the u.s believe those consequences would
be
well uh we're not going to
comment i mean i'm not going to
speculate on on
empty threats or threats by president
putin or by russian leadership what we
have done here is done exactly what the
president said we would do from the
beginning which is to
if they invaded we would be providing
significant security assistance
economics assistance and support to the
ukrainian people and we're going to
continue to do exactly that
but i i want to belabor this only
because we've heard from the airlines
from airport passengers there may be
people sitting in an airport bar
watching right now wondering
if they're boarding a flight tonight is
the mass mandate still in place we're
continuing to recommend people wear
masks i don't have any update this just
came out through the courts just this
afternoon and as soon as there is an
update uh we will provide that is the
white house anticipating
an announcement by homeland security
tonight
they are assessing it right now and as
soon as they have an assessment and an
update on additional steps they'll
they'll make that available but if the
doj say doesn't stay the order tonight
or first thing tomorrow morning
our passengers
i understand why you're asking and
certainly no one here is trying to
provoke uncertainty with passengers we
also think the mass mandate should be in
place and that it's safer for
individuals who are flying to continue
to wear masks so we would say to anyone
sitting out there we'd recommend you
wear masks on the airplane and then as
soon as we can provide an update from
here hopefully soon we'll provide that
to all of you two more related cdc
things in the ruling the judge said that
she accepts the cdc's argument that
masks limit covet's spread
but that alone is not sufficient to
overcome what she concludes is a rule
that exceeds the agency's authority to
put it in place
the administration believes otherwise
right
otherwise we wouldn't have put it in
place to begin with so that potentially
is the crux of
an appeal or an attempt to stop well
again i would leave that to the
department of justice but uh all what we
what we announced last week uh was just
a two-week extension in order to have
time to assess what we've all seen is
rising cases and and and make an
assessment recommendation uh with that
in mind so of course it's disappointing
there's another issue the cdc is in the
middle of that's troubling some
democrats and that is of course the
impending end of title 42.
gary peters who chairs the homeland
security
committee another democratic senator
today suggesting
he has doubts about ending title 42
says that secretary mayor is scheduled
to be there for a budget hearing i
believe later this month and next month
what more though is the administration
sharing with these democrats
and republicans but notably a handful of
democrats who say they don't see a firm
plan they want more details and the
administration seems to be rushing into
this with no sense of what the
repercussions could be well i think it's
important to remember this is not an
immigration authority for anyone who has
concerns about it nor is it an
immigration plan we've never said it was
it is a health authority that congress
gave the cdc authority to make a
determination about about whether it
needs to stay in place or not there is
no question we have a broken immigration
system there's more we need to do we've
been saying that from the first day the
president took office and anyone who
wants to work on that democrats
republicans anyone how we can put
smarter security in place how we can
have an asylum processing system that
works we would love to do that but what
their what is happening right now is
they're essentially holding hostage
funding for kovit and we are going to
run out of funding we are already
running out of funding for key programs
so our issue here is let's move forward
with the covet funding we're happy to
have a discussion about the broken
immigration system we agree it's broken
let's work together on addressing that
say that because there's this amendment
to the code that would put it i say that
because that's the root issue here isn't
it i mean anyone who's raising concerns
they're tying it to
uh they're tying it to the coveted
funding
republicans are but you've got a handful
of democrats who aren't necessarily i
understand that but we're also happy to
work with anyone on on immigration
reform and any concerns they have but it
sounds like the answer is
if you've got concerns you congress do
something about it
well
here's what happens on may 25th the
president put forward a bill his first
day in office
it's not you do something about it let's
work together on it and we're happy to
do that you have different ideas you
want to talk about how to move this
forward let's do that at the same time
what's happening is this coveted funding
which means people who are uninsured are
not going to be able to get access to
treatments to vaccines we're going we're
not going to be able to get the fourth
booster shot to everybody we're not
going to be able to get uh the
treatments for immunocompromised so
that's where we're at and that's why
it's important to move that funding
forward and yes our system is broken
let's address it but this is a health
authority not an immigration authority
thank you jen
you said about this mass ruling out of a
federal court in florida that it's a
disappointing decision and you say you
continue to recommend that people wear
masks
why is it that we can sit here in the
white house briefing room with no masks
but people
can't sit in an airplane cabin with no
masks well peter i'm not a doctor you're
not a doctor that i'm aware of if you're
a doctor i wasn't aware of that today
until today
okay not a doctor just making sure i
don't know um
nor does he play one on tv there you go
most days um but these determinations
remember the masking guidance is there
are is green yellow and red we are
currently in a green zone in washington
dc so they're not recommending it some
people can still wear a mask if they
want to many people do or wear them in
meetings or wear them at certain times
where you're going to be around or
sitting close to people or maybe you
have an immunocompromised parent or or
friend and so people make that decision
and there's this is based on health
considerations and data that the cdc
looks at about transmissibility as as
we've seen increasing cases on on
airplanes would the president's support
if a flight is leaving from an airport
in a green zone those people don't have
to wear masks again peter there's a
there's been long a difference from the
beginning about people on an airplane
and in uh federal transportation
vehicles and situations than where they
are in locations like we here here
continue to be in washington d.c a green
zone but what we'd ask for i think it's
important to remember is a two-week
extension or not asked for what we had
announced was a two-week extension to
look at the data and make
recommendations based on the data and
the science about whether it should be
continued or not okay on a different
topic we have new reporting that at
least 23 people apprehended at the
southern border in 2021 are on the
terror watch list
why do you guys think it is that
somebody on a terror watch list would
want to get into the united states
undetected
well i can't make an assessment of that
but what i can tell you is that your
data you're citing here means the border
patrol was doing their job i mean they
they apprehended people at the border
illegal immigrants a day
got away last month are you saying that
you can say with certainty none of them
are on a terror watch list here's what
we're talking about encounters we know
and of suspected terrorists attempting
to cross the southern border they're
very uncommon we're talking about a few
dozen annual encounters that most at
most and these encounters represent
significantly less than the 0.01 percent
of total encounters per fiscal year in
recent years but i'd note these
individuals these 23 people the border
patrol they stopped them they prevented
them from getting into the country
they're protecting our homeland and
keeping us safe so the president is not
worried about
holes in the southern border being
exploited by people trying to come in
and kill americans he's grateful to the
border patrol for doing their job and
and stopping these people and preventing
them from getting into the country one
additional question about something that
happened a few months ago down at the
border we've been told that the mounted
border patrol officers the president
accused of whipping migrants have been
notified they will not face criminal
charges so when is the president going
to apologize to them
there is a process and an investigation
that's gone through the department of
homeland security i don't have any
update on that the president said that
they were whipping people which would be
a criminal offense and they've been told
they're not going to be criminal and
there was an investigation into that and
i'll let the department of homeland
security announce any conclusion of that
investigation you accuse these officers
of brutal and inappropriate measures now
that they've been told they will not be
criminally charged will you apologize
and peter there was an investigation
into their behavior so that
investigation is playing out is whenever
they're it's uh going to be announced
the department of homeland security will
announce that and i'm sure we'll have a
comment on it after that go ahead uh
back on the mask issue as the debate is
going on about next steps is there any
concern in the white house that this
issue now that there are some americans
who are aware of this ruling by the
florida judge that it could prompt some
of the tensions we've seen on airplanes
in recent months until there's a
resolution yeah kelly it's a great
question obviously what we're trying to
do what we would encourage is calm in
all cases and because this ruling just
came out this afternoon i know the
objective of everybody involved and all
the necessary authorities in government
is to make a determination about next
steps as quickly as possible so
that's certainly our hope and we want to
do everything we can to prevent that on
the oil leases um
does the president see any secondary
benefit to the fact that even though
this is not his policy objective that
there could be some um additional
production that could help given the
fact that gas prices are high and there
has been a push to have additional
production because of the war in ukraine
even though it's not his policy
objective
i can tell you from talking with him
about this this morning he does not um
he believes that
as he announced and he remains committed
to the ban he called for on the
expansion of
of leasing on federal lands
in part because he wants to move toward
a clean energy economy and he's very
committed to that and address climate
change but also because there's 9 000
unused leases that can be tapped into
and used and we certainly have
encouraged oil companies to do that to
help address exactly as you said the
need to get more supply in the
marketplace he sees this move by the
department of
interior as
a
going against his campaign pledge
well he sees he knows that it was the
result of a court injunction as you
heard uh secretary holland say and so it
was uh her hands were tied in many ways
as they can be by legal uh by legal
requirements but what they did which he
certainly supported was take steps to
reduce by 80 percent the areas to lease
and they also imposed stringent
environmental safeguards in order to
take additional steps even as the court
injunction
made them take these steps you did not
mention cuba as a state sponsor of
terror should we read into that i did
not mean to not mention them i wanted to
cite some examples just to give people a
sense of how few there are and what
kinds of countries i wasn't meant to
you're not listening i'm not announcing
new policy no i'm not i'm not announcing
new policy i just wanted to give an
indication of what that is and how
limited the number of countries are go
ahead thank you this is a question that
comes from one of my colleagues who's
reporting in ukraine right now he is
wondering
you know as conditions in mario paul
continue to disintegrate is the united
states considering any
creative ways to help the ukrainians who
are under siege for instance sending in
third country planes or planes from a
neutral organization like the red cross
to get relief in there
so
you mean humanitarian relief
we are engaged with surrounding
countries with aid organizations about a
range of ways to get aid and assistance
in and obviously
from the start of this if there was if
there was an allowance or an
implementation of these humanitarian
corridors it would have helped enable
but we can't talk about a lot of those
things from here but we are going to
continue to take steps to provide
humanitarian assistance in every way
that we can i would no you didn't ask
this question but just one other little
update there were four uh planes that
arrived of military assistance over the
course of the weekend
another one today is supposed to arrive
today if it hasn't already
from the 800 million package the
president announced so just to give you
a sense of our efforts to continue to
get more
assistance in and completely unrelated
but today on a background call about
climate policy an administration
official said that the white house is in
touch with a wide range of members of
congress about a reconciliation package
so are negotiations ongoing for
buildback better or building a better
america or whatever you're calling it
now and are you talking about it
we we are talking about it um whatever
you call it a reconciliation package um
including uh getting a historic
investment in climate including lowering
the cost of child care elder care um
and healthcare taking all these steps
that the president has been committed to
these conversations have been ongoing uh
over the course of the last several
months and are there is joe manchin
involved in those conversations who are
you talking to we're talking to
everybody across the board i'm not going
to name all the names but they're all
included democrats across the board uh
who want to get this done
what i'm is the u.s moving any closer to
reopening its embassy and keep now that
spain is joining france italy and others
and doing so well certainly that's our
objective um is to open it but what we
um what we are evaluating is
obviously security considerations and
when the state department is prepared to
do that um so when we look at kind of
who should go first and how many and how
many people and when but it's all done
through the state department
and they make those initial
recommendations about when to return but
that certainly is our objective
obviously having a diplomatic presence
on the on the ground is important just
one more thing um president silinski
says the russians have begun their
offensive to take control of eastern
ukraine what is the administration's
assessment of what's happening there now
uh well i know that my defense
department colleague just did a briefing
so i'd really point you to the
department of defense for any kind of on
the ground updates
um yesterday on cbs senator kuhn said
that without the west
coming more forcefully to ukraine's aid
he said quote i deeply worry that we
will see ukraine turn into syria does
the president share that concern that's
not a words or phrase the president
would use or we would use from
from the united states obviously what
we've seen to date is the ukrainians
bravely fight back against the russians
and
win essentially the battle of kiev and
continue to fight back against their
efforts across the country we've known
and predicted that they would move their
ground game uh to eastern ukraine which
is exactly what they've done and we also
have known and predicted and when when
jake sullivan was here uh just a week or
two ago he also conveyed that uh they
were like that moscow was likely to
launch air and missile strikes across
ukraine to cause military and economic
damage that's what we're seeing in la
viv and other and other places at this
point in time but uh what we've seen i i
think is is them behave uh bravely with
huge courage and they have they have had
the success in pushing back against the
russians because of that but also
because of the military's assistance
provided by the united states so no we
would not share that assessment on the
diplomatic front um is the
administration any closer to naming an
ambassador
i certainly understand the question i
don't have any update on that at this
point from here
go ahead thanks john um i want to ask
about a story some of my colleagues
reported earlier today
um some allies of former president trump
have been pressing for state houses
around the country to pass resolutions
for sending electoral college votes for
president biden and to bring lawsuits
that seek to prove baseless claims of
large-scale voter fraud
legal experts have called this effort
preposterous but is an organized push
among those allies to certify the last
election something this administration
is monitoring or concerned about
uh well i would say that there have been
dozens of
of court cases
that have
not been won by our predecessor and
people who support him in an effort to
overturn the outcome of the last
election and our focus is on governing
for the american people delivering for
the american people
and less on focusing on what he and his
people are up to
go ahead yeah thanks jen i wanted to
follow up on the question earlier
regarding senator kuhn's comments yeah
one of the
points he was making was that the u.s
needs to have a conversation about
sending uh us troops to ukraine he told
face the nation yesterday uh quote the
american people cannot turn away from
this tragedy in ukraine i think the 21st
century turns on how fiercely we defend
freedom in ukraine and that putin will
only stop
when we stop him
what's the white house's response to
this suggestion for the senator that the
u.s needs to start having a conversation
about maybe sending troops to ukraine
and does the president agree that uh
putin will stop
when we the u.s uh only when we the u.s
stop him
well what i would say is one senator
coons is a close friend of the
presidents and the administration and we
just respectfully disagree with his
proposal
the president continues to uh has no
plans to send troops to fight a war with
russia he doesn't think that's in our
national security interests in the
interests of the american people and so
what our focus has been on has been
obviously providing this historic amount
of security assistance military
assistance weapons to the ukrainians
that has helped them effectively fight
this war and economic assistance as well
this is also strengthening their hands
at the negotiating table even well we
are putting in place a historic package
of economic sanctions that as i noted
earlier even the head of the russian
central bank is noting the the
devastating impact of these sanctions on
the russian economy so that has been our
strategic focus um of course we support
the ukrainians
in every way possible but the president
is not going to fight a war with russia
go ahead
um the president has done or will do a
lot of travel in recent days to place
those yeah so-called house frontliners
are running for re-election and i wanted
to know if you could talk about how much
um political considerations are laid or
taken into consideration on the white
house's side of the president and also
if what kind of an impact do you think
of any role his discussion and promotion
of things like the infrastructure law
will have on voters as well
well i'm always careful about what i get
into about politics from up here i've
learned my lesson um but what i will say
is that
the president is proud to go out in the
country in blue states red states purple
states
to talk about his agenda both what he
has achieved including the bipartisan
infrastructure law that is rebuilding
roads rails and bridges and uh and uh
and replacing lead pipes around the
country expanding broadband access
across the country in communities no
matter what your political party is and
he's also proud to go out and talk about
his uh his economic agenda he's still
fighting to get past which includes
child care health care
elder care and reducing costs and his
view is that for anyone out there
when they're out there
senators or members of congress who are
going to be talking to their communities
that standing up for his agenda and
standing up for this agenda that will
make the american people's lives better
is a is a winning argument um so i would
say um
i wouldn't i'm not going to overly note
the the political sway of districts or
states but he's always said he wants to
be the president for all people govern
for all people and that means talking
about his agenda in red blue and purple
states
go ahead
jennifer going back to coronavirus um
some of us recently here and around the
country have been taking home tests
to diagnose ourselves um
and when those come up positive
those aren't always reported to public
health and sometimes they can't be
sometimes they won't even accept that
do you believe that we have an accurate
sense of the spread of the coronavirus
right now
well i think what's important to
remember is that um
one cd but how cdc uh continues to track
covet cases that are reported they do it
really through hospitalizations and
death
and those numbers around severe disease
come directly from hospitals and states
and what we're seeing through those
is that we're at the lowest level
hospitalization since the start of the
pandemic i believe we're still at that
point in time so we certainly encourage
people to share their test results and
contact their doctor because they may be
eligible for paxlovit or or any other
therapeutics
but you know beyond that as i think i
would note when we put out the
president's hundred page plan we noted
that our focus was really on
hospitalizations deaths and severe cases
uh even as we're encouraging people to
report testing for contact tracing and
other purposes when they test positive
untitled 42 there is a bipartisan group
of senators including cinema mansion
some who are at risk including senator
kelly who say who are proposing the idea
of letting the surgeon general certify
when the public health emergency has
ended is that something the president
would consider and then why or why not
well the seat congress gave the cdc the
authority uh so uh
and i'm wondering if you're open to that
idea well i don't have any projection
prediction of that at this point the cdc
is the public health authority for the
country so i don't i don't i don't have
any more predictions go ahead um
japanese prime minister kishida just
announced japan taking in a group of
refugees which is really a big deal for
japan and the foreign minister hayashi
flew back a group of
refugees from poland to japan his
administration aware of that and and
then also with the trip to japan next uh
month uh any update on whether an
interview with the
president is an offing
oh it's an interview pitch okay um
i said oh an interview with whom um i
like your style um
uh we certainly welcome and applaud um
the actions of um of the uh the the of
japan the japanese leadership
and are grateful to uh their steps in
taking in refugees and their
humanitarian support through this
conflict um and they're an important
partner as you know um uh and uh have
been a part of important meetings uh on
the conflict in ukraine in recent months
including on the president's last trip
to europe um i will certainly take under
advisement your request go ahead eugene
thanks jen um there have been kind of a
growing growing rumblings among economic
economists about the r word recession on
that coming possibilities
i was like where are we going
yes
and i guess i'm just curious how the
administration is viewing the
possibility of that and what kind of
conversations are happening right now
about a possible recession well we
continue to believe our economist most
importantly that the united states
economy will deal with challenges ahead
from a position of strength because of
the president's economic plan it's
important to remember we created more
jobs last year than any other year in
history
we obviously have a very low
unemployment rate in the country and
we've seen wages go up in a number of
areas i would note that there was a
goldman sach we may be referring to this
the goldman sachs analysis
and even in their analysis they said
quote we still do not see a recession as
inevitable however particularly since
the fed's goal of cooling the economy
while avoiding a recession will be
helped by postcovid normalizations in
labor supply and durable goods prices so
our view is we're in a period of
historic
job growth strong business investments
strong consumer and business balance
sheets and normalizing supply chains
those are all good signs for the economy
but obviously we'll continue to monitor
uh any any concerns we have about where
things are headed and as then if
inflation continues to rise uh what are
the concerns about that if there's about
making a lot well the federal reserve
continues to project that it will
moderate uh by the end of the year uh
and they obviously we support their
steps they've announced to recalibrate
um and we've already seen some of those
actions taken uh but really that it's
under their purview uh so we would point
to their projections go ahead uh so just
a follow-up on title 42 the issue that
democratic senators have brought up is
that there isn't a detailed plan they
think to to deal with the expected rise
in migrants of the border so does the
white house feel confident that the
administration has the necessary
resources and operational plan in place
to process and house and transport
migrants well i would i would point to
the fact that the department of homeland
security put out a plan that they
briefed members on when we announced the
timeline or the implementation period an
extended period that wasn't immediate
at the time that includes surging
resources and making sure we had
the type of resources available
to meet any needs um so they did put out
a preparedness plan at the time but
we're going to have continuing
conversations and we certainly welcome
any engagement to do that our issue is
more the hooking it with covet funding
because of the devastating impact that
would have on communities across the
country just a another question on
a times op-ed that senator warren wrote
today
saying that democrats need to deliver on
more of their agenda in order to keep
the majorities in congress
do you agree with that premise and at
this point i know you named a few of the
legislative priorities already uh in the
briefing but
are there top three priorities that the
white house feels they can actually get
done before the midterms
we love all of our children in the
legislature around here
what i will say is that
you know we've talked a bit about
steps to lower costs which i know
senator warren of course strongly
supports as well for child care for
health care for elder care
for prescription drugs these are
no-brainers for most people in the
country and also making the tax system
more fair we think those are all issues
that democrats but also a lot of people
around the country would love for us to
do more on and love to talk about more
we of course as i've stated a couple
times in this briefing want to get coved
funding because we think it's essential
so that we can continue a lot of the
programs that have had such a huge
impact on people's lives including for
the uninsured including uh in making
sure we have boosters for fourth
boosters for every american who wants
them whenever people are eligible
including being able to buy enough evas
and for and treatments for the immuno
compromise that's hugely important to us
and then of course we
we want to get the innovation act passed
because we believe that
that's something that should have
bipartisan support and
we want to make sure we have
manufacturing here in the united states
something that can make us stronger over
the long term there are many other
things but i would say those are a
couple of the things that we will
continue to fight to move forward with
the premise that
the administration and uh democrats in
congress need to get more done in order
to have a shot at the majority i would
say i'm not going to make political
predictions from here what i will say
though is that
everybody looks at a choice and what
each party is fighting for is advocating
for has gotten accomplished but also
what their vision is for the future and
we're proud of our vision
to go back to the virtual coveted summit
yes mentioned again need for congress to
approve coveted funding does the white
house see that date may 12th for the
summit as a deadline for congress to get
that funding approved we don't but we
just see it as a reminder of how
important it is um that to uh to
continue to take steps to be the
provider the va the arsenal vaccines to
the world something we have already done
since the since the last summit
while the world has made significant
progress in scaling up vaccination
efforts and kova and kovacs has now
provided almost 1.2 billion vaccines to
more covax yes to more than 140
countries
uh with 88 of those contributions going
to low and middle income countries we're
not at the global vaccination rate that
we need to be or that
health experts project we we want to be
at right it's a 70 vaccination target
that's the global target set by the
world health organization and while
vaccination rates are rising only
approximately 20 percent of countries
are fully vaccinated at least at least
70 percent of their population but this
is an opportunity obviously we're going
to continue to fight for more funding
here but we will to continue to press
other countries to do more uh to help
the world make progress as well and
along those lines you know we've heard
usaid chief smith the power say earlier
this month that if there isn't that
global coveted funding if congress put
something together without it that the
u.s would have to turn its back on the
countries that need urgent help to boost
vaccination rates will it be difficult
for the u.s to take a lead at a summit
like that if that funding has not come
through well we are far and away the
leader in the world that will not change
between now in the summit regardless of
funding however we want to continue to
be and continue to be providing not just
vaccine doses but also the know-how and
equipment and supplies that countries
around the world need
more mass shootings this past weekend
more mass shootings two teenage boys
dead
dozens injured
what does the president believe is
causing such a callous disregard for
human life in this country
well let me first say and thank you for
the question um these shootings are
horrific and must stop our prayers are
with the survivors those who are lost
and their families i can't attribute
obviously this just happened over the
weekend the reasoning but what i can
tell you is that it's a reminder of the
need to take more steps to stop gun
crime something the president has
strongly supported and advocated for
since for decades in public office
cracking down on gun traffickers putting
more cops on the beat investing
community anti-crime programs and and of
course also confirming a very qualified
individual steve dedlebach
to lead the atf
you know
what does the president have in mind if
anything a plan to improve to
to
to get people to respect life more to
respect other human beings laws aside
you can't legislate morality values
right human life
does ever talk about that openly to you
or anyone else i think every time that
you've seen the president talk about
shootings the impact on families on
human beings
on loved ones on communities
he talks about that human impact and but
it also is true that in order to
reduce and change the direction of crime
and gun crime which is the majority of
crime
we need to change we need to have more
laws in place go ahead well thank you
texas governor abbott said that quote
financial pain was necessary to get
officials to take action on illegal
immigration
um is there any sense that those border
inspections did cause financial pain
that there was any disruption
supply chain or anything like that that
you all are tracking well while i don't
have an extended summary um summary
analysis uh what i do know is that you
don't have to look farther than the
comments made by business leaders trade
organizations of all political stripes
and parties and their opposition to
the unnecessary
additional
steps that the governor was implementing
and there's one million dollars
in trade crossing over the u.s mexico
border every minute so there's no
question that
putting these unnecessary inspections in
place which resulted at the time in the
drop in commercial traffic of up to 60
to 70 percent in some ports was having a
huge impact on the local community on
businesses and that's why so many people
were so outspoken about it and just
quickly do you have an update on the
plan for ukrainian refugees will it be a
parole program like you have for afghans
or any other yeah i certainly understand
the question i don't have any update in
this moment that's exactly the type of
program but there are a lot of
considerations so hopefully we'll have
more soon
thank you jen does president biden have
confidence in senator dianne feinstein
steve con
senator dianne feinstein yes she's a
long time friend a proud public servant
and someone he has long enjoyed serving
with and working with after that report
came out last week questioning your
health did the president reach out to
her at all i don't have any updates on
private conversations
thanks everyone